[Music]
hi and welcome to
tonight's lecture
prepare like a pro i'm going to show you
two examples of games that were won by
black thanks to
a very good home preparation
um
in two different styles one is a victory
of mine in 2012 so 10 years ago
when chess engines were not that
powerful
and one is a victory by duboff who is
one of the most creative players in the
world in 2019
woo's preparation was much deeper than
mine but
i mean there are two
these are two different ways to prepare
and
with the help of these two games i would
also show you a little bit how to
how to use chess base and
and the material that goes with it so
let's start with my own games i was
playing against
grandmaster ryzen zev with the black
pieces
player before
but second it was also
the last game
before
the french federation decides on who
will represent france in the next
olympiad
um
and well the four spots were more less
clear and i was fighting for for the
first spot for the fifth one so
it was quite important to do well that
day and not to end
uh with loss that's what so i was really
uh i i really wanted to to do my best in
that game well i i always wanted to make
my best when i played but that game was
particularly important
anyway at the time i was playing the
gruntfell defense and i noticed when
preparing for the game that my opponent
was playing the bishop d2 variation
which is which is interesting it's been
played recently by very good players
um and it's also tricky for example
anand beat nepamyachi in less than 20
moves just a few years ago
um
just because nippon nachi confused the
move there somewhere i don't remember
the the exact game but he just lost
without within the opening
and the way i prepared for that game
was the following i only had my laptop
i had chase base i had of course
a big database with
millions of games
a database that you everyone who has
chase base
has as well because it usually comes
together as a package
and of course i had a chess engine but
not a very powerful one first of all it
was 2012 not 2022
and uh
and it was just my laptop
not a not not like a very
expensive uh home computer or something
like that like that so anyway
i had little time to prepare
i saw that my opponent was playing this
line here knight b6 is a possibility
actually it's also a possibility here
right away
um if knight b6 then bishop is three
and the idea behind bishop d2 is
obviously to take back with a bishop on
c3 after knight takes his three
so this is the main line
or at least one of the main lines
and i was working on this position and i
was trying i was trying to look at uh
what what had been played and
um
and i was trying to
see what the engine was recommending for
black here at the time there were the
theory on this variation was not too was
not as developed as it is now
um so
well for the first thing to do when you
when you want to prepare is to look at
what has been played before so then you
use reference
so
unfortunately now it would take some
time because
the search booster
has to be created it takes a few minutes
so
well should we take this two minutes now
i think it'll keep going
if uh well i'm not sure
we better wait
we better wait two minutes i think
so while we're doing that uh let me move
your mic just a little bit because okay
there you go
okay
um yeah how do you know in these lines
which is like a critical position to be
looking at
either the engine or
looking at
like
what's been played so the first thing to
do is to look at what has been what's
been played that's why
that's what i that's why i am taking
this
to i mean
that's why i want to wait this two
minutes to
this search booster to i mean this
search booster you only have to
do once and after that
it works for life
but
nobody ever did it on this computer so
how did you do that function how did you
initiate that so i just clicked on the
reference
notation is where you have the moves
and references to look at to look for
the games that have been played
and it's very important to show
the display i mean to show the result of
this
reference search
because it's a really it's a very useful
tool for for working
obviously nowadays you can also i mean
you have plenty of information for
you have plenty of information
everywhere and actually for a very small
amount of money compared to
10 years ago i mean now you have such
you have excellent chess books excellent
video contents everywhere
and
many variations you can get a full
repertoire just
uh coming from a gm just spending a few
dollars i mean
you can have a very book a very good
chess book for 30 dollars and it gives
you a full repertoire that uh
that takes perhaps 100 or 200 200 hours
to do by yourself
so i mean
nowadays we have this uh this luck that
we have access to everything and we have
computers it's not like 30 years ago
when you know there were there was chess
informant and the top grandmasters were
traveling with like
50 kilos of books
full of chess
full of chess games
and and so on i mean now we have chess
engines we have chase bass
and
look how easy it is for example you look
at this position you see that e6 has
been played
39 times and you can already see that
it's been played by gritschuk villit
erdos hammer
so that means it is a very reliable move
same goes for queen d6 which has been
played by nepamyachi and vashiragrav who
are two big kurunfeld specialists
then you have knight d7 but it's been
paid only four times it's been played by
vashira graf
but the last thing last time was in
2016. so you may assume that if
bashirograph played another move later
then it means that 97 should be inferior
it doesn't mean you don't have to look
at it especially if you are white you
have to look at all the moves but as
black
the there are 99 chances that the best
move in this position is either e6 or
queen d6
and well for example in that game i
didn't play e6 i played queen d6
to which my opponent played the most
logical move f4 so there are many games
but i think there are mostly recent ones
i mean the game my game was 2012 you see
that you barely have any game you ha you
have one game here in 2011 and
uh mine might be the second
the second oldest in in the line
because queen d6 is a pretty weird move
f4 is very tempting for white
and uh well actually queen d6 as i said
uh was almost new when i played it so i
was just trying to
understand it uh working with with a
computer and the engine well you can see
that now e6 seems to be the main move
it's been played by nepali achiever
graph
so it's a sign that it should be the
best move
but at the time these games were not
existing and my laptop my engine were
was suggesting 97 which is probably not
that bad anyway because for example i
see that sam shankland played it six
years later
so it cannot be too bad but it's a very
strange concept because white just goes
e5 and then you have to go back with the
queen
it seems pretty weird
so
i was preparing on the line and the
engine was the engine was assessing
these positions around equal and i had
no game to help my to to help me
i could only use my brain and my and my
the chess engine
so the chess engine okay here you have
uh deep fried which is a little bit
outdated now nowadays it is much better
to use
houdini or stockfish or commodore
there is also lila now that uh that
exists
uh but anyway
the engine the engine was there to help
me but i knew that it was not like 100
trustable because it was just uh
because it was not very powerful
but i thought that
in that position if i were white i would
definitely go h4 you know after all
these weird moves 27 97 so now
the going to for this this research i
see that grand master only chuck played
uh
knight f3 that might actually h4 has
only been played in my game and later
two players played
knight f3 so it might just be a better
move but at the time
i i simply thought first the first
question i asked myself was okay what if
white plays c4 it looks like it has a
wonderful center but of course if c4 i
have knight takes e5
and the knight can be taken because then
queen takes and queen takes work
so
the way i was thinking that position is
what is what are the blacks perspective
perspectives and what would i play if i
were white the plan for black is quite
clear black one c4 knight b6 rock d8 and
to target the d5 bone
and i thought if i were white in that
position i would definitely go h4
because the white king seems completely
unprotected
um the bla the black pieces all went to
the queen side the queen
white won a lot of time in the center
and generally when you dominate the
center then you try to attack on the
side and
on the opponent's king if you can i
really thought if i were white i would
go h4 in that position so i decided to
try to push it with the
computer of course h5 is a logical
follow-up
so night i followed
the computer line
now of course i was verifying things
like i don't know f5 with the idea to go
queen h6 and so on but it never works
because e5 is hanging so knight f3 is
definitely the move
bishop g4
i was analyzing this
position so context is definitely
logical
now taking with the h pawn would be too
much because after f5 or followed by
queen h6 well maybe f5 doesn't work
because e5 is
again in the air but well something like
this
well you see why the engine is useful
something like this with a queen coming
to h6 is highly suspicious for black
so fg is very logical here
it activates a rock the king is a little
bit more it is a little safer and i want
to play rock 88 and take the d5 pawn
so why should attack here and already by
then you see that here the engine is
suggesting is an ig5 or rock h4
these are the two moves that i've been
looking at when preparing for the game
but i definitely spent more time on
knight g5
which seemed which seemed to me much
more critical than rock h4 i mean rock
h4 takes
takes
um i mean that doesn't look too straight
too straightening for black with the
rock coming to d8 and so on it is true
that the bishop is also coming to h3 but
i mean knight
g5 just like h4 i thought what would i
do if i were white and definitely knight
g5 is a move i would go for
just just
bringing as many pieces as possible
to the attack
then rock 88
i mean when i was working on the line i
was
finding it pretty suspicious i would i
would not have been surprised if
suddenly the engine would have shown a
win for white you know
but it did not after rook 8 it turned
out that black was holding this position
if y just takes on h7 for example let's
say with the knight
then rock d5 and it's just turning to a
disaster for black
for example queen there rock takes f4
queen takes f4 rock takes e5 check
and then rock f5 and black is just
completely winning
so d6 is actually the only move for
white
black has to take and rock h7 is
extremely logical as well
just taking the h7 pawn and attacking
the black queen but the engine was
insisting that black is fine in that
position
rock h6
is a logical move
and here the engine wanted to take
and after analysis i realized that the
best blue white can do here
the only way to actually save himself
is to well it can start with
actually the move order doesn't matter
you can start with knight f7 or even
with rogue h6 but the only way for white
to save the game is to play f5 um i have
a
you have to plug the
laptop band
because it's the battery is running low
yeah
the f5 is the only way for white to save
the game then after rock d2 there is a
perpetual check here
which can't be avoided
after i my opponent play knight f7 i
mean rocket h6 the engine is very
illogical because after king g7 it looks
like a nonsense but after f5 white is
still in time to make a draw because if
i take the rock then knight f7 check
and there
i'm getting
checkmated
unfortunately
and if it's charging right now it is it
is
my opponent played knight f7 i played
king h7
but of course i was just repeating
everything that i had been working on
before the game for the simple reason
that i've been trying to sit in the
shoes in my opponent's shoes
thinking what do i would play with white
and what he what he played with white is
exactly what i would have done
so
of course i i could have gone wrong
because my opponent was
a stronger player than me
on the other hand the variation was
pretty forcing and
well again in that position the only way
to save the game was to find f5
because it's threatening mate on h6
queen h6 mate so i have to take the
queen and white is in time to
after rock takes queen to come back and
then again give this perpetual check
but at this moment i was already very
confident why because i had two hours on
my clock i didn't have to think for a
single move and my opponent was already
playing with 30 seconds and i knew that
if you want to save the game he had to
find this f5 idea
and he did not he just played
rock h6 jack and now after king g7 this
is just completely lost for white takes
takes the rock is untouchable
because of queen e3 followed by queen
takes c2 checkmate
and after rocket rock takes the eight
the rock is hanging the queen is hanging
it's basically over my opponent played
rock h4
i took on the two
okay my opponent has two uh rocks for
the queen but with such a weak king
basically
the wall position is collapsing all the
pawns will be lost
so the game continued for a few more
moves and then
my opponent uh just resigned
so basically uh
i beat my first 2700 player
in what i would call a no game i did not
have to think a single move in that game
um
when my preparation finished
um i mean the moment my preparation
finished was here when he blended with
h6 check and after king g7 it's already
minus five it's i mean it's already a
position
that uh anybody anybody would win
against anybody
and how did that happen simply because
i could guess what would be the human
reaction in a very tense position and
here h5 i still believe i mean now now
of course i know that
the engine
uh i mean also
people know that uh h4h5 is not
necessarily working because as we as as
we saw uh other strong players played
knight f3 instead but i was really
confident that my opponent would play
the play h4 because it really seemed
very logical to me and
well this way i could guess basically
all my openness moves which were all
very logical i just anticipated them and
even with the help of the of a quite
weak engine i could just uh i could just
win the game
without without any effort
that's also a tip i got uh
by by french road master etienne backrow
once
uh but i think that i think that was
later but uh
in one in one game i remember at the
beat
a little bit well i won't i won't say
who was a player but it beat an ex a bit
a bit an experienced uh grand master
with the white pieces
somebody rated like 26 30.
he beat him out of the opening
and i was pretty surprised because he
had anticipated
what was
known to be pretty bad for for black but
he had anticipated like it
the way i mean it felt like uh
he was sure that
that these bad moves were coming uh were
going to happen and i asked him after
the game how is it possible that in this
critical line you were it just it looked
so normal for you that
your opponent played this uh these moves
that are known to be dubious he said
because weak engines are suggesting
these moves
another and when we had this discussion
engines were already stronger it was
possible to get better computers
that were refuting the line
that backrow was talking about
but he said
i knew that my opponent was not
preparing with a good computer so i
simply
on purpose did not use a strong computer
i put a weak computer on the position
just to see what you would most likely
prepare and this way you anticipated all
the moves
so he said um actually the exact
sentence he said is
uh if you want to
play some if you want to beat somebody
who is using a bad computer use the same
computer
and
that's that's a sentence i
i i always remembered
um
nowadays it is more difficult to to win
games this way because it is so easy to
have access to very strong
computers for example
um here we here we can see it on the
screen
but there there are now now you don't
even need to buy a very expensive
computer to
uh to use a powerful engine you have
cloud engines that are provided by chase
base and uh just for a few cents per
minute you can get
some of the best uh chess engine in the
world
uh they're not using uh even your ram
memory on your on your computer so you
can even use a
very very very bad very old computer and
just for a few cents per minute
you can have a very powerful engine
helping you this is called cloud engine
and you can you can have a look at it
on chessbase.com
everyone has access to it and this is a
reason why it becomes
tougher and too tougher and tougher to
beat
weaker opponents especially when they
are young and computer addicted
because everybody has access to the same
information at a very low price
this is what makes a chess so different
now than it was 10 years ago
so this was a preparation based on
intuition
but this is obviously
not the only
way to prepare for
well i don't have a choice it's written
in mate in one so my preparation was
just take the queen and make a draw
that's it
there is nothing i could do even if i i
mean i i did have two hours versus a few
seconds but had he found a five there
was nothing i could do if i don't if i
don't capture the queen i am getting
mated on the next move so i would have
to make a draw
so i knew there was a draw and at this
moment i was really hoping that he would
i mean at the start of the game of
course with the black pieces against a
stronger player i was i was happy with
the draw but at this moment of the game
obviously i was really hoping he would
not find this move f5
and it is not surprising that he did not
find it because with 30 seconds
it is not like uh the first thing that
comes to mind to just uh allow your
opponent to capture your queen and it is
not a very usual usual perpetual check
yeah
so
that game by duboff was played seven
years later and this is a totally
different level of preparation much
higher than mine i mean much harder than
the one i showed
in in the previous game
nowadays it is very difficult to find
new ideas in openings because everything
has been cleaned up i mean
everybody has been using very cloud
engines and all positioned the series
has been cleaned everywhere to move 20.
i mean if you play against somebody who
is well prepared i mean to to out
prepare him uh i mean this
it is basically it is almost impossible
to and prepare to out prepare him so for
example in that game duboff was playing
against jerry with a very very talented
tannish kid i mean
when i met him
a few months ago i think he was
still
17 if i'm not wrong so 2019 he was 14
and he was already he was already a
grandmaster or maybe he was not
grandmaster but he had 2500 as you can
see on the screen
and well he was a hard worker
so to beat him in the to beat him in the
opening especially with black is
something that uh
that you can only manage with a lot of
creativity and a very strong engine
but duboff managed it managed it duboff
is
one of the most creative players in this
uh perhaps the most creative player in
the world actually
he is the one who
is the one who
always finds finds new ideas everywhere
when others just do not do not find any
there is a reason why magnus carlsen was
asking him to prepare him for the match
you know about this
uh this
uh
i'm missing i'm missing the world
no no well i mean yeah the world
championship but i mean there was this
conflict uh this between russians
after uh well not as big as the current
conflict but uh
there was a there don't know there was a
conflict between russians and dubai
because dubai held magnus prepare for
the match against uh nepam nachi who is
russian just like dubai
yeah well not conflict of interest but
they were claiming that uh
it should not help carson uh beat
someone from his own country so there
has been uh well
for for several days or weeks people
were always talking about it
but okay dubaf i mean just did his job
as he said he agreed to work for magnus
for the match even before
learning who the challenger would be
and
well you know you can't just
of course you have to be patriotic but
if you have a chance to work for several
months for magnus
you're working with the best player in
the world for several months
you're getting a lot of money for that
uh it's also a lot of prestige
to tell the guy that he should have
declined is a complete nonsense that is
my opinion
uh but there is a reason why why even
somebody like carlsen wants to do buff
in his preparation team because to buff
simply has a lot of ideas and what he
found in that game against jerry in 2019
was amazing and obviously
the creative part is found by duboff
himself
because engines i mean this is why
engines are unbeatable uh
engines
have no are not affected by psychology
so
if something doesn't work
the engine will just
not mention it
because
well if it if it doesn't work even if
there are 10 ways to go wrong 20 ways to
go wrong if there is just one way to go
right
it's not going to suggest that idea
because
he knows he knows exactly how to refute
it
um but if you if you could prepare
clever in a clever way
um well this is
um
how to say that um
what is a good and nowadays you can't
just out prepare your opponent by having
a better chess engine or better chess
book or better chess coach you can only
out prepare somebody by finding a
creative idea and how to find a creative
idea you have to fight against the
computer you have to actually
find one of these lines where the engine
claims that there is some for example
some advantage for white
um
but there is a difference if for example
um
a move is bad and
the refutation is obvious or the movie
is bad but it leaves white only two
choices
and even if you consider that
it is not easy to choose the right
direction there are still 50 chances
that your opponent will go wrong
so
a good preparation nowadays is when you
are able to find something where
there are many ways to go wrong and only
one way
to go right and this is what duboff has
done in that game he found an incredible
uh
creative idea so he went for
this line aiming for a martial
gun beat so c3 d5 would be mainstream
theory that would be the martial gun
bits this has been played millions of
times not millions but
thousands and thousands and thousands of
times and by all all top players and
here two moves are called anti-martial
one is h3
and one is a4 these two moves are just
supposed to
prevent
d5 in the position
this is why they are called anti-martial
and incredibly enough dubai in that
position played d5 anyway that was
totally that was like a revolution you
know uh a4 just you know a4 just
threatening eight xb5
and you play d5 anyway just like nothing
happened this was this was quite
incredible
pontex d5 was played
so after ab5 his idea was probably to
take
take bishop g4
and for example
if you switch on the engine
it says that white is much better at the
beginning
but give it some some more time
so this is where you have to find it
fight against the computer or actually
it could be that here it was ef-3 first
queen f3 and e4
and you see the engine is claiming that
white is better
but in fact this position
uh
for human i mean the engine is claiming
that white is better so
that's the reason why nobody's thought
of playing that with black because the
engine says 070 so people think okay i
won't play something where i'm clearly
worse where the engine says that
white has a clear advantage immediately
but if you look at this position
optically i mean or
perhaps even bishop g4 first
um it's very hard to play for white look
he wants to go queen f1 here do you
really want to play such a position as
white
if you are well if if if you anticipated
everything and you know that it is
better for white
then okay you go for it bad luck but
over the board
i would personally if i were white i
would not go for such a line where all
the black pieces are developed and my
king is weak my queen is on f1
almost trapped
that looks to me like massive
compensation for black although if you
really push the engine does not agree
with that
so it was
so duboff found this uh found this idea
ed5 is also is also a critical move now
knight xd5 would not be a great idea
because that would be a little bit too
much
that would be really too much
but here he played knight a5
he wants to capture the bishop and he
wants he wants to play some kind of
martial gambit for example after knight
e5
black can take
take now we should be careful
uh that knight c6 does not happen
so
i'm not sure queen d5 is too great
because after knight c3 we're losing
time but maybe something like that and
again if knight c6 takes takes well
actually this is a game sorry
um this is a game this is a game um
but for example see the engine also says
that bishop a2 is good but after e4 it
it wants crazy lines it says knight e5
only way to be better and if i remember
correctly there was some move here
and then the only continuation was
somewhere some knight f7 i don't
remember how it
worked exactly was it bishop d6 here
no bishop d6 is just d4
um
i've been analyzing this game but
unfortunately could not find my analysis
uh before the lecture
because i know it was it was from three
years ago it was my on my old computer
and i could not find it
um
but anyway it's also a position that
looks very unclear i mean the knight on
e5 has no square
that's not something and you see the
more you wait
the
more the evaluation goes down
and it's not a position you want is
white yeah and um you ha and you have to
if you have to i mean there are tricks
everywhere simply and what uh what white
played in the game was also
very intuitive i mean
this is really as i said something that
looks extremely dangerous for white
after e4 of course if the white pawn was
already on d3 then it would be a
completely different position but e4 and
bishop d6 bishop g4 this is something
you do not want as white so this is
something you easily anticipate knight
b3 and bishop b7
now definitely the only move for white
to try something is knight c6 because if
you just recover the d5 pawn without
losing the bishop pair you have great
compensation
you have a great version of the martial
gambit so knight c6
definitely critical
and it can be pretty discouraging that
als again here the engine says that
white is better
i mean many many players they would just
stop they would think okay
after a b5 the engine claims that there
is some advantage for some advantage for
white after bishop a2 as well
after knight e5 as well many players
would just give would just give up and
and think okay this is this is not a
reliable idea but duboff understood that
all of these positions are difficult to
play for white and here after bishop c5
the best for white would have been to go
for something like d4
and try to
exchange many pieces for example uh be
sure for example knight is three and try
to go bishop h3 just action some pieces
or perhaps ab5 here
um knight t4 is the only move you can't
take because of take and takes and take
on d4
so that was also a computer line that
duboff has prepared that is 100 sure
knight e4 you can't take the knight
because of bishop f2 and queen takes
queen
and
bishop h3 has to be played
takes takes b5
and for example such an endgame okay
you're not
you're not you're not going to win as
black as black or perhaps knight a3 uh
not knight c3 you're not going to win
this as black but you're going to make a
draw which is
not that bad as black
i mean
even if it was irrated i mean what to do
he's black he is finding some creative
idea but
okay you can't uh to be better with
black is something that does not happen
very often nowadays and it's it's hoping
to play d3 which is the most logical
move because d4 is clearly drawish
and d3 is definitely what looks critical
because you want to play bishop e3 you
want to keep an extra pawn in the
position white has two extra bones but
your dubai found bishop takes f2
move that at first the computer was not
showing but now look well once you show
it it already drops your relation to
equality
and
actually it says equality
um and it's it and it's and it's a quite
weak engine that we're using right right
now so you can imagine that using a very
strong engine it was probably showing
bishop takes f2 immediately
and after takes in queen d4 it is
actually extremely difficult for white
to make a draw
if i remember correctly
i mean there are many moves the white
king can go back to f1 but then after
knight g4
it's very ugly i mean queen f2 is a
straight knight h2 is a strat
um the rocks are coming in the center
white is completely underdeveloped on
the queen side and even the engine
claims that
white is fighting for equality
as far as i remember
bishop p3 was still fine
no actually bishop b3 loses i think king
f3 was a draw if i remember correctly
black can already play queen g for queen
d4 but you may also play on but i think
it was uh it was holding somehow
uh yeah i mean if if we if we let it run
uh i don't
maybe it finds something but if i
remember my analysis correctly that was
a draw for white but who wants to play
king f3 in this position i mean after
queen d4 the position is already so
frightening and white played bishop e3
knight g4 checking f3 this is more
natural than king f3 right away because
at least you are forcing some exchanges
but this is also a nightmare to play for
for white if take stakes at first the
engine claims that white is fine but
actually
white is
not fine at all the rock is coming to e6
this is going to end very badly for
white
and after rookie 2 as in the game black
played queen f6 king g3
of course black could have repeated
moves but your g5 is just a forced mate
you want queen f4 and queen h4
rock f2 is base is pretty much the only
move
check
check
if king g3
you get mated right away
so king g4 queen h roy and white
resigned anyway because queen f5 there
would be quintex rock and the game is
over
so
duba found that game in just 23 moves
with black just reinventing completely
um
the martial gambit
uh playing d5 in this position so let's
have a look for example at
the games that at the existing games
the move d5
it could be that it's been played a few
times since duboff played it
but okay that was 2019 so let's sort out
by years
okay some players played it you know
very a very long time ago
then for
the it was then basically nobody played
it for uh
for many many years
until i mean okay there is one between
2008 and 2019 there is only one game
by some
1800 player who was definitely
unprepared see after pantex he played e4
so he was just playing random moves
definitely he did not play d5
because he was prepared he just played
it like that over the board
so
you can basically say that during 11
years it was not played
even that game
after pawn takes
black did not go knight a5 but played e4
so
this game does not really count either
2005
okay the 2005 i mean so let's say that
almost in 15 years it had never been
played
and duboff reinvented it and of course
since duboff played it then it's been
repeated by many many players because
they all understood it is a very
interesting idea
so where is the double game
yeah it's here okay and then of course
after that many players started to
repeat to repeat it because duboff
showed way but duboff was the first
let's say in the 21st century
to understand that d5 in this position
is tricky it is probably objectively
better for white and 90 of players just
did not consider it because of the
engine evaluation that goes completely
against it
but
duboff got it right he found many new
ideas he understood that many of the
positions that the engine assesses as
better for white
actually seemed very
inhuman to play for to play
and if he found this bishop takes f2
idea
in that position
he probably knew that if he's opponent
to play d4 he was unlikely to win the
game but this three is definitely what
you i mean
as white you're supposed to play for a
win especially in a match i mean
especially in a team
competition
and if you want to and if you want to
do if you want to
to beat or even to draw against russia
you have to try something with the white
pieces because you're you're you have
you are worse on all the boards
uh you need to try something with the
white pieces and this three is
definitely the way to try here i mean
just trying to keep the pawn and play
bishop e3 and keep some extra material
and look after bishop f2 it would be
very difficult to to hold this position
for any human i mean give that position
to carlsen to play as white maybe he
will find
maybe we'll find a maybe he will find a
way to draw but i'm not even sure i mean
it is so difficult to play
so that was that was a very deep that
was a very deep preparation
um
a perish i can show preparation of the
same kind which i am
deeply oops i just closed closed the
notation accidentally
okay let's have a look at the mega
database in chess base
okay i haven't selected the games
because i sold these two games
would be enough for one hour but let me
show you something similar
um so
i'll try to find the mega database
oh actually it's here i see it okay
so for example
i i was working
as i already said i was working with
stopolo from 2010 to 2014.
so let's have a look
and
that position
is
a main i mean this is a main
line in the queen's gambit
c5
kramnik likes to play knight h5 in the
in this position i mean ironian likes to
play with c with c6
which gives white time to play h3 and
keep the bishop
knight e4 is a trendy line in the
in the in more recent years
uh but knight h5 has always been
kramnik's favorite moves just uh going
for the bishop
and uh
toboloff and i found this interesting
idea bishop e5 which nobody had
considered because if you switch on the
engine
it says that after knight takes e5
you need to take with the knight not to
be worse
and okay this position is definitely
nothing for white
there are even people who commented on
the game uh on this game of uh this game
topper of kramnik
and said
this is a mystery how toppolov could
play knight could play this bishop e5
move when after knight takes e5
uh
there is definitely nothing for white
and actually this has been played even
in a game
nakamura anand or nakamura i don't
remember
although it's not happening here but i'm
absolutely sure there is a game of
arnold in this position
which went knight e5 knight f6 and of
course there was no advantage for white
but our idea was to fight against the
computer and to prove that d5 was very
interesting in that position
we are straightening g4
trapping the knight so the engine claims
that black is better after g6 but we
simply strongly strongly disagreed with
this evaluation there we want it to go
g4 and h4
and the engine doesn't like it it wants
to it wants to take a pawn but then we
wanted queen c2 or perhaps h5 first
perhaps h5 first because sometimes
the queen develops somewhere else
and in fact if you push the position
there is a very strong attack coming for
white queen c2 lone castle bishop d3 and
there is a very strong attack on the f
on the f file
see the engine wants bishop e7 okay let
let's let's play the first engine moves
and you will see that the evolution just
drops it wants to go to play like this
okay let me play for example
bishop d3
or maybe not bishop d3 in that position
yeah maybe there it is not bad to double
rocks
okay it already claims the position is
equal and if you push and push and push
you realize that actually white has a
very strong attack
so that was a bit similar that uh
we simply thought okay if after de5 the
way to for black to be better is to go
g6 put the knight on g7 and suffer this
incredible attack
uh this position is impossible to
underlast black
and we had a very deep analysis on that
position
which is perhaps objectively fine for
black but uh
just extremely dangerous i do not even
think that black is better in this
position whatever the engine says
because we put a lot of effort i mean
we spent i don't know how many hours we
spent on this position where i spent
more hours than him because well we were
finding the ideas together and then i
was
i was a second so i was the one pushing
them
but uh
together we we spent perhaps 50 70 hours
in on that position
uh i mean on the wall on the wall line
after bishop e5 and we understood
that it's very tricky for black
and actually kramnik kind of knew it
because he played c6 very quickly he did
not play knight takes e5 which is a
computer recommendation
um
he played something with g6 topolov
played h4
and kramniker played f5 which was pro
which was dubious
then the bishop came back to h2
and uh well actually the pawn on h4 was
not such a big deal black can take it
but then it gets
in big trouble
on the queen side queen a4
takes takes
and it's you see white is already
winning
um
and if it has okay it's knight b8 only
move you see i mean this is just uh
this is just a horrible position to play
for black and there are many
lines like this after bishop e5
unfortunately there are also lines that
are good i think
i think f6 is best
and then c6
so that uh so that you can
so that white can never push his h pawn
because of knight takes
g3 i think this is fine for
uh for black but then
several players repeated the line that
for example
i know that you so and on the camera
this is a game i was referring to
all right it was slightly different okay
bishop if
bishop e5 c6 was played
okay but g4 or g1 in that position was
not yeah that was not
threatening
um but just after topple off on that
game yotov repeated the line but after
bishop g3 here his opponent immediately
took
and again
in a position that at first the engine
claim
came that black is doing fine after
bishop d3 f5 g4 white white as at a
terrifying attack take stakes
black played c4
white took
black play knight f6
white sacrificed
queen c2
then knight g5 the queen is coming to g6
then knight f7 checkmate is basically
coming
so black had to give away a lot of
material and was just
lost
and resigned couple of moves later
so the idea was very dangerous but if
you if you only use the engine
it will say that the move is
stupid if you only use your brain it is
bad as well because you need to know how
to answer against the computer
suggestion because it is likely that
your your opponent will have checked it
with a with a computer and you need to
know how to anticipate so when you're
working when you when you want to really
prepare
like a professional you need to use boss
you need it
the preparation needs to be a mix of
human ideas human intuition and computer
evaluation this is what makes the
difference between a good second and a
bad second because everyone can just
push the button press press the press uh
push i mean here you push you put do you
you can put the engine on
you leave it for
you leave it for okay let's
go back to the main game you leave it
for some time then you press space bar
and it plays
uh the first engine move then you wait
for another two minutes and you do it
again but this everybody can do and the
first time i met topalov he said
i had seconds like this
but if i only need somebody to
press a button every 5 minutes
i rather give the job to my wife i won't
hire somebody
even if she does not pay chess
then i rather
pay my wife to do the job instead of
hiring
a grandmaster
uh spend and spend uh
spend money for him to press the space
bar so
uh
this is uh this is a double of a second
basically to
uh
find creative ideas
uh that the computer will not completely
destroy because if uh
well if the line is too bad it is just
too bad of course we found it this idea
we stopped off with d takes e5 and then
g4 h4 and we
assessed it as very very playable for
white but we also had many tries that
were wrong and that we
decided not to use because
they were just uh they were just too
many ways for for the opponent to
to to to react well against them
but we also had many ideas of this kind
that were
that that we considered very difficult
to play for the opponent and okay that
one brought him a nice victory against
kramnik which was not very useful
in the end because he won that game but
he finished last in the tournament this
tournament did not go well
uh that was actually is uh
is only bad tournament from the years we
worked together but it was really bad
i think it's called -3 or something like
this
but anyway well he did not in the end he
did not care very much because he said
you know the candidates there is one
winner and seven and and there are seven
losers and to be second or to be eight
doesn't matter
you qualify for the world championship
or you don't qualify
um
so
uh but still okay that was that was a
nice that was a nice victory
uh based on a human intuition
and then pushed with the help of the of
a chess engine because of course it
could be that the attack would be a
total fail and then we would we would re
we would uh give up on this bishop e5
idea but we found out it was uh it was
highly interesting so that is that is a
way to prepare
you need to
you need to find you need to find ideas
i mean the the basic is of course to
learn the theory to know what
others know for that you have just books
you have jazz videos
you go to
you can buy stuff on traceables if you
want to write to watch videos you can
watch you can buy books on sinkers
publishing if you want to buy a good
chess books
there is good material everywhere
but then if you want to really out
prepare your opponent and you want to
find your own novelties
it has to be a mix of uh your intuition
and
the help of the computer
this is this is exactly how topple of
beat kramnik and this is also
this is also how do both beat jerry in
the game we saw
just before
so i don't know if i've been
clear enough in my explanations
and
only question is so let's just say let's
just pretend you're analyzing an attack
and then it turns out that it's like
-10 for black but it requires like five
only moves would you still
consider going for that or no minus 10
is a bit too much if it's really if it's
really lost depends on the tournament
situation as well let's say that you
need to win
and if you make a draw then
okay let's imagine you're playing the
world cup
and uh you lose the first game
it's a two games match you need to win
the second game absolutely
and you don't care whether you make a
draw you lose
then okay why not try but generally
minus 10 is a bit too much but if it's
minus one for example
and that if
requires to find five only moves
uh which are difficult to find then you
can consider going for it
but this is pretty much the limit you
can't i mean you can't either afford to
be completely lost out of the opening so
for example this bishop e5 we know we
knew what was the best reaction for
black
but in case black would do that we knew
basically how to more or less equalize
with white and just have a have a normal
game right it would be a disappointment
but we knew how to limit the damage and
we knew that the damage was not enormous
and same goes to duboff if white knew
what to do it would it would not be
completely winning it would just be
slightly better
so let's see if i missed some questions
in the in the chat
okay people say chess base should be
free well but you know chase base is a
company and
a company has many employees and
if they give away their products for
free
um they won't survive very long
okay alternative
mm-hmm i would say
alternative it's not great but
well it's
it's different i mean but i mean also i
mean chase base is not only the software
just based as uh
many things of course i mean it
developed many things not only the
software
um
okay some things you can get for free
for example you can download tweaks
every week
and then you don't have to buy the mega
database every every year
some things you can get for free but not
everything and it's normal because
otherwise there would be no business
around chess if everybody had to give
away his work for free then you can also
say that uh when dubai has a chance to
work with carlson he should work for
free because he is also learning when i
worked for topolof i should have done it
for free because i was also learning um
okay
you work and you get paid for that and
it same goes for chase base
and other
and same goes for book publishers and
video publishers and
and so on
i don't see too many questions in the
chat so
i think that's it for for today
if you don't have any more questions
all right
[Music]
you